bye
welcome councillors to this meeting of
annual council
before we begin i would like to leave
the council in a two-minute silence
in honor of his royal highness the duke
of edinburgh
former chair of this council council of
frank
taylor and former consort stuart
huckabee
bye
[Music]
[Music]
thank you members i would like to invite
the vice chair to say a few words
thank you chair on the 16th of april i
attended a service at derby cathedral
on behalf of northeast derbyshire in
commemoration of his late royal highness
the prince philip
duke of edinburgh we received a message
from our twinning partners
from the land christ of darmstadt
dieberg
which read we learned with regret
that prince philip passed away at the
age of 99.
we will keep a lasting memory of his
impressive personality
as well as his enduring efforts for the
british
german friendship
on behalf of the conservative group i
wish to say a few words about former
councillor
frank taylor who has died aged 87.
i had known frank for some 20 years
he was a straight speaking person with a
dry sense of humor
he had been a counsellor in
nottinghamshire prior to joining
northeast derbyshire
i consider frank to have been
fair-minded
which he demonstrated as chair of the
overview board for scrutiny
he listened to views of all parties and
accepted contributions from each
councillor
he did the same as member of the
licensing committee
now always remember frank for ensuring
the
funniest event ever in a council meeting
but it's too delicate to share on a
public
live stream he was chair of the council
in 2002
during which time he helped to promote
camtad
a charity for deaf people in the local
area
our thoughts are with sheila and their
family
our thoughts are also with councillor
huckabee
whose husband stuart has recently passed
away
stewart had been consulted the council
from 2019
he was a larger-than-life character who
made a significant contribution
to his local community it is typical of
stewart
that he fought his illness with strength
and dignity to the end
express sincere condolences to carol
and the family thank you chair
thank you thank you councillor becker
before i formally open the meeting i
would like to say that as the outgoing
chair
it has been an honor and a privilege to
have been the first citizen of north
east derbyshire can i remind members
that this is a public meeting being
streamed
live to youtube and bear the council's
website
the meeting is also being recorded for
the purposes of the minutes
i have been advised that the live stream
is now up and running
if for any reason the public can no
longer hear or see the meeting over the
live stream
we will adjourn until the connection has
been reestablished
can i ask the governance manager to
explain the procedure for
the meeting and to confirm the members
and officers present
thank you chair um and good afternoon
councillors
this is just a gentle reminder to you to
comply with the virtual meeting
etiquette
which includes keeping your camera on
during the meeting
but remaining muted unless requested to
speak by the chair
the rules of debate are applied as per
the constitution
please request to speak by either
raising your hand or writing speak
within the chat bar
voting today will be undertaken by paul
and
please ensure that you've got your
closed captions enabled
those members who are in attendance
today
chair are yourself cancer and cliff the
chair of council
council armitage councillor barker
councillor birkin
council clough councillor cooper
councillor cupid
councillor dale casa dayton councillor
elliott
councillor emmins councillor angelique
foster councillor mark foster
councillor fennell councillor gomez rini
councillor hall councillor hancock
councillor hartshorne
councillor holmes council hutchinson
councillor kerry castle lewis councillor
liggett
councillor lilly councillor parkin
casa pickering councillor potts
councillor powell
council reader counselor renick
councillor ridgeway
councillor rowe councillor ruff
castle rouse apologies our mr councillor
rouse council shipman
council stone castle tate
council thacker castle welton councillor
whitehead
councillor windley council brian wright
and council philip wright
also in attendance we have um two of our
three new civic cadets who are joining
us remotely
councillor lee hickens is the head of
paid service
sarah sternberg who's with you in the
council chamber today as the monitoring
officer
karen hansen the director of environment
enforcement jane dethick who's the
section 151 officer
members of the it team and the
governance team who are supporting this
meeting
and any other members of staff who are
here to assist with any of the reports
to be discussed today
thank you chair thank you let's move to
our first item which is the election of
chair
of the council can i please invite
nominations from the floor
[Music]
so dale thank you
chair it gives me great pleasure to
propose my colleague and friend
councilor martin backer
mbe uh for for the position of chair of
the council
council thacker was born and raised in
walton where he still lives
and is an extremely passionate advocate
for northeast derbyshire
he's represented brampton and walton
ward on the council since 2007
and has served as chair of holly moore
side and walton parish council
since 2009 more so than anyone else i
know
councillor thakur is a community-minded
person who has dedicated himself to some
extremely valuable causes
he served as president of the staby
branch of the royal british legion
stably armed forces veterans association
north derbyshire rspca
uh chesterfield male voice choir and the
island collary chesterfield brass band
and that's just to name a few of the
many civic and voluntary organizations
that i know he is very proud to be part
of and to support
he also supports young people through
organizations like the scouts
and the raf cadets and as a keen
football fan he's also vice chairman of
chesterfield football club
and a director of the community trust
which i know
given the highs and lows of the club's
performance must be a real
labour of love one of the causes that is
most dear to his heart
is supporting the deaf community and has
campaigned valiantly over the years on
their behalf
in the year 2000 council athacker was
recognized for his fantastic work
with an mbe for his services to the deaf
community
as leader of the council martin led an
ambitious programme of reform
delivering on the count on the manifesto
commitments that brought this
administration into power
as the first from our party in the
history of this council
his finest achievements though came at
the onset of the pandemic
when his community-minded instincts came
to the fore and he helped to transform
the council
almost overnight so that it could play a
hugely important role in supporting our
residents through the worst of it
i think we all know the the levels of
support that went in but just to
highlight a few of the things we had 7
000
residents registered for support with
the council we delivered 4 000 medical
supplies
there was food parcels newspapers and
magazines delivered to all those who
needed them
and 18 million pounds worth of grants
were given to support local businesses
and none of this would have been
possible without the efforts that
that council thakura himself put in and
it's that real passion for the community
that helped to bring that to the fore
and given his track record his
community-minded instincts and his
already very important role in public
and civic life
i know councillor thakur will be an
excellent chair of this council
and will work tirelessly for the
advancement of north east derbyshire
and his chosen charity thank you chair
thank you councillor cooper
thank you chair i'm really pleased to
second council of thakura as the
chairman of this council
for the year ahead i paid tribute and
note my thanks
to yourself cancer ancliff for your
brilliant efforts in adapting the role
of chair
during extraordinarily difficult times
to support your chosen charities
and with that the last year i think has
shown that the role of chair of this
council
has had to change quite dramatically and
from the work council of thakura has
been doing during this time
both in supporting yourself and for this
council and the local charities
as councillor dale has just outlined as
well as his experience and community
links
demonstrates to me that he's the perfect
person to continue to adapt the role of
chair
where needed but also hopefully this
year to return to some of the big things
and events and fundraisers
as and when we can to me council thakura
fits the profile to be a really good
first representative of this council
and district on two main fronts which i
wanted to highlight
firstly i really welcome council of
hackers plans and commitment to revive
some of the civic traditions
as has already been done with the civic
cadets closer links with our armed
forces
the flag protocol and hopefully will be
continued with the appointment of a
civic chaplain in a few items time
it's really important to maintain and
revive these traditions
i feel particularly with the local
community as just another way for the
council to support our district
and to build our links with other areas
and groups secondly as has been
mentioned many times i think in this
chamber before
but can't be repeated enough council
attacker has a positive
and quite amazing record of dedication
to many local groups and charities
there's actually too many for me to list
although i know councillor dale has just
had a good go
um and i'm unsure how councillor thakur
manages to be in so many places at once
but i know this will make him a really
positive representative and advocate as
chair of the council
and also gives him ample experience to
support his nominated charity this year
supporting councillor thakur and his
very ambitious but welcome plans for the
year
i understand will be gene spencer as his
consort
i know gene shares councillor thacker's
tireless energy
for supporting charities and local
causes and groups
as she's a volunteer at chatsworth which
is where i've often seen her
but also has a long-standing commitment
to chesterfield and district
sir optimus i think where she is
currently president
and which supports many charities and
important causes in this area and
internationally
so i know gene will be the perfect
consort to the chair in representing our
district and supporting as many
residents and groups as possible
throughout this year and meeting with
them i wouldn't wish to give any
spoilers or preempt anything
but i'm really looking forward to what
councillor thakur has already hopefully
been planning
for hopefully his time as chair even if
i can't quite convince him to
launch a chairman's cheese but the most
important thing here i know is the
driving force
for both council of waka and jean is to
raise as much as they can
for a charity very close to them and
indeed i think close
to many if not all of us in the virtual
chamber
and also in the district so i'm
delighted to second council of dale's
nomination
and hopefully without contest i wish
them the very best of luck
for a hopefully very very busy year
ahead thank you chair
thank you are there any further
nominations from the floor
no indications chair
we will conduct the vote by a show of
hands
please can the governance manager issue
the vote now
so members you should have a poll on
your screen
asking for you to vote for against or
abstain
for the proposal to elect councillor
martin thacker as the chair of council
okay i'll just give it a few more
seconds for the final votes to come in
okay and i'll end that there and share
their votes for you
and nikki there's two four in the
chamber at least that would make 40
votes for
with four abstentions
but nomination is carrichure
thank you
hey may i be the first person to
congratulate councillor thakurani's
election as chair of the council
and invite him to make the declaration
of office
thank you chair um i martian edwin
thacker
do you swear by almighty god having been
elected to the office of chair of the
northeast derbyshire district council
that i take that office upon myself and
will duly and faithfully fulfill the
duties of it according to the best of my
judgment and ability
i will bear true allegiance to her
majesty queen elizabeth ii
her heirs and successors according to
law
so help me god
thank you and i wish to thank the leader
and deputy leader for their
proposal on second and for the very kind
words from both of them
thank you and also to my fellow
councillors for electing me to the
position of chairman
i give you my reassurance that i will
undertake the role
with diligence in signing the
declaration of acceptance of office
i held the bible given to me by my uncle
and auntie
who were also my godparents
they were profoundly deaf and both
inspirational people in my life
but for others too they're no longer
here to witness this day
but if i carry out duties in a way that
they would have been proud of
then i will have achieved one thing
i know i will be ably supported by gene
who has been my mentor
for almost 30 years she will be a
wonderful consort
the chain of office of the council
chairman is symbolic of tradition
since it displays the coat of arms of
the district
the arms bear witness to the area's
mining past
and its riches as a rural place
the links are symbolic of togetherness
i would like to think the role of
council chairman is one that brings
every community across north east
derbyshire together
as one district the velvet collar
the chain sits on is known as a yoke
the purpose of a yoke in general terms
is to spread the load
while the chain is a symbol of civic
authority divested in one person
the responsibility is a shared one since
every one of us is elected to serve the
residents of north
east derbyshire i hope all of you will
share a collective willingness to work
together
for the benefit of the district
particularly as we prepare for a
post-pandemic world
i also hope you will support me in
fundraising for my charity over the
coming months
my chosen charity will be ashgate
hospice care
and i'm delighted to see charlotte
gratton on behalf of the hospice
here with us this afternoon they are a
charity cited in brampton and walton
ward
represented by peter elliott and myself
everyone is aware of the excellent work
the hospice does
in providing specialist palliative and
end-of-life care
as well as support given to adults and
their families across north derbyshire
please help me to help the hospice
during the next few days i will be
launching a talent competition
with a chance to win a cash prize trophy
and opportunity for the winner to
perform on match day
at the technique stadium tickets for a
grand prize draw will be on sale
with unique prizes to be won and a pink
gin distilled by derbyshire gin
distinctly
has been produced called chairman's
choice
look out for details of these and
forthcoming events there is a lot to
look forward to
over the next year thank you for your
trust
in me
item 4 apologies for absence
i have apologies already submitted from
counselors huckabee
cornwell and kenyan
are there any other apologies councillor
barker
before i go to that martin there there
is a
is is uh count clan cliff not going to
say oh done
outgoing chair of the council but if not
uh we are doing we haven't got to that
part of the agenda yet
i'm sorry i'm just just testing this is
my first mistake
uh great start i'll be coming back to
that in a second i'll do apologies now
and then i will come back to council
market
we can join the comedy competition that
means yes
we'd win it
i've got three councillor barry hill and
cornwell i don't know
that they the three i've got from our
group thank you i've got councillor
jones
yes to say i'm sorry i was late
attending it was due to a technical
problem
don't worry thank you it's good to see
you any other apologies
no then we'll go to item three
um which is the address of gratitude to
the outgoing
chair of council so councillor and cliff
is no stranger to civic duties
having served as consort of the council
in 2005.
however she could not have been prepared
to take office
at a time of worldwide pandemic
in spite of covid council and cliff
endeavoured to represent the council
at events such as vijay commemoration in
harimore side
an event in memory of the poet edward
carpenter
civic remembrance and fundraising
activities wherever possible
for her chosen charities
i admire her determination to promote
both causes close to her heart
she has chaired meetings of counsel
online
which everyone knows is no easy task
and i've just proven it in spite of
technical difficulties and barriers that
it's sometimes present
councillor and cliff has always retained
her poise
as a friend and colleague i am very
aware of the additional work she has
undertaken on behalf of this council
behind the scenes while it may not have
been the year we would have envisaged
i believe the best thanks of the council
should be recorded to council and cliff
for the grace and dignity in which she
has conducted herself as chair
for the civic year 2020 2021
and it is now my privilege to present
council and cliff
with a past chairs badge and an album
recording her year
in office and some flowers which have
just been presented socially distanced
and counselor dale we should say a few
words counselor dale
thank you chad just just really echo
what you said there i think it's been a
a hugely difficult year for for the
chair of the council for
for council rank cliff and i feel
extremely disappointed that the
the civic year fell in the way that it
did but i just want to say
how much i admire uh council rancliffe
for
how she's approached it and and how well
she's actually done
in raising money uh much needed for
funds for her
uh chosen charities and we know that the
pandemic has been difficult
for all charities so um every little bit
that counts franklin has
raised has been so important and so
useful for them
um we know that uh chairing meetings is
is immensely difficult at the best of
times when we're all in the chamber and
i can't imagine how much more so
uh over zoom uh but but ken franklin has
always approached it with
approached it with a huge amount of uh
amount of dignity and
and and poise as you say uh and has done
extremely well so for me
council franklin is absolutely the
councillor of the year uh and i'd just
like to say a huge huge death of
thanks to her for everything she's done
on behalf of the council
so thank you chair thank you council
dale council barker
that was used to echo well after that i
think uh
it's been really really difficult uh
back for you and
uh council ranked cliff uh very
difficult times
uh and i think the term grace and
dignity
sums it up uh martin i think she's been
brilliant
uh and and done her very best in very
difficult circumstances so
uh it's it's not been easy for you and
and i it's a shame that you dropped on
that year but
that's it somebody had got to have it uh
and and if she wants to be to
council of the year add second device
thank you council market council
yes i mean what can you say other than
the what to echo what everybody else has
said
i've known pat for a number of years she
served with me on our wingerworth parish
council
and i wish her well it's been a
disastrous year regarding charity work
for her but she's
done her best and she's raised quite a
significant amount of money
and i look forward to serving with her
for the rest of the year thank you
thank you council liggett
well what a year to be chair i know how
important
uh councillor and cliff's charities are
to her and how hard she's at to work
to raise the money she has but it's sad
that the events that council and
clifford clan could not go ahead due to
kobe 19
but i would like to say well done pat
for what you have achieved
thank you thank you
and uh councillor and cliff to reply
thank you for those kind words i've
written a little speech actually
and i'd like to just continue
this year has been a year like no other
one which has raised challenges as a
result of the implications of probit 19.
it has not only led to a change in how
many others work but in our daily lives
as well
that said once it has been challenging
it has been an honor and a privilege to
have been chaired during this
exceptional and unforgettable year
charities have been severely impacted
during this crisis
yet it is at times like this when they
are needed the most
i have a number of fundraising
activities planned to support my chosen
charities
alzheimer's research and the deaf
children society but social distancing
and lockdown meant these could not go
ahead this meant that more
inventive ways for raising funds needed
to be found
i couldn't do this alone without the
support of my team and i would like to
thank
them for their creative ideas and in
managing the online events
whilst this meant that we couldn't raise
the amount of money i would have liked
we did manage to raise quite a bit
considering the circumstances
a sum of nearly 4 000 pounds has been
raised to date
and just to remind you the donation line
is still open for the next two weeks if
anyone would like to donate
please do i would also like to say a big
thank you to my vice chair
councillor martin thaku now chair
for his unwavering support i would also
like to give special thanks to dave
vickers
and joe bradley and to acknowledge my
two volunteer cadets
however most important i would like to
say a big thank you to everyone
who has been able to donate and finally
as my year draws to a close i would like
to wish the incoming chair
council martin a very successful year
i sincerely hope that social distancing
and lockdowns don't
impact on him the way it did for me i
wish him an enjoyable year
thank you
thank you thank you counseling cliff
item 5 declarations of interest members
are requested to declare the existence
and nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interest and or other interests not
already on their register of interest
in any item on the agenda and withdraw
from the meeting at the appropriate time
no declarations
move to item six minutes of the last
meeting can we please approve as a
correct record
the minutes of the meeting held on the
8th of march 2021
council dale yeah happy to uh propose
that we move those thanks chip
and counselor cupid
yeah happy to second those thank you
chair thank you
council barker
thank you chair uh just before that i
didn't get a chance to congratulate you
on being being made the chair of the
council
and uh i'm sure you'll uh carry out your
duties as you've said in your
contribution
with the uh the utmost uh
best of your ability anyway and i'd like
to personally put on record i want to
help
towards ashgate hospice and help with
your fundraising activities so we're
well done on that uh just on the minutes
uh there's a couple of things one that
counter lily's apologies are not
recorded and i'm fairly sad now i put
those in
uh and and secondly uh i just find it
odd that we've got
the minutes of an ordinary meeting in
middle of an agm i don't know
does that usually happen i thought
they'd have been better in the next bit
the next meeting
but that's just a point of order
i thought i think councillor barking
answered the first bit we can
make sure they're amended and council
lilies apologies added
in terms of the the second point
probably so um
but if we content just to um continue
that they're here um and they might as
well stay here
and thank you for running rugged with
the agenda and throwing in anything you
you fancy in any
agenda right or wherever possible so
i'll keep you on track council barker
so it's been proposed and seconded uh
all those in favor of the minutes
hold on to a poll now all right could
you show could we do the
poll then please
chair just final vote coming in now
nikki there's two four in the chamber
that would make uh
45 four unanimous chair thank you that's
carried
thank you move to item seven the
election of vice chair
of the council uh councillor dale
thank you jer i'm very happy to
uh propose counselor diana ruff uh
council ruff is an extremely hard
working councillor who
uh like yourself chair is uh is also
very community minded
uh she's previously served as chair of
wingwood parish council for a number of
years
and as a district council i know she's
made some fantastic strides in improving
the planning committee
as its chair as well as been a really
active member in other committees
i know she'll do a fantastic job in
supporting you
as the chair for the forthcoming civic
year uh yeah i'd just like to
propose councillor diana ruff and wish
her well as your as your vice chair
thank you and secondary council cupid
thank you chad yeah i'm more than happy
to second councillor ruff
um as vice chair of the council for the
coming year
i know from speaking to councillor ruff
that she's really keen
to as vice chair to engage with young
people
and to try and obviously link them into
politics more etc
so i think that's a fantastic cause as
well as the the charities and
organizations that she's involved in
already in the local community
so wholeheartedly uh second thank you
any other nominations barker
okay i'd like to move councillor betty
hill
uh very similar to what's just been said
about councillor ruff really betty we
all know betty
i don't think i need to say an awful lot
uh but she's
uh yeah i'd like to move here as the
vice chair
for the for forthcoming year thank you
thank you do you have a second
council reader yes i'd like to second
council betty hill
betty's worked really hard in grassmore
she was a a brilliant deputy leader of
the council she's worked many years over
the council so i'm happy to second
council betty hill
thank you any other nominations
if not then we have two nominations then
councillor danny ruff and councillor
betty hill
um so governance have you prepared a
poll
for both names um yes i've just done
that chair would you like me to
put that up on screen yes please
so please vote now
just waiting for one for the vote to
come in
um nikki there's one four in the chair
in the chamber okay she'll end up
pulling that
and with the one for uh counter rough
within the chamber that would make that
29 votes for councillor rough and
uh 15 votes for councillor hill thank
you
commiserations and to councillor hill
it's not a personal reflection everybody
knows her dedication to the community
but congratulations to councillor diana
ruff who is duly elected
as vice chair of the council for the
civic year 2021
2022
we move to item 8 appointment of civic
chaplain
the traditional role of the civic
chaplain is to offer spiritual
pastoral moral support and guidance
to the council chair councillors and
employees
in resurrecting the role the intention
is to ask the chaplain
to assist at times of celebration
mourning and local or national
reflection
reverend nick greene of st john's church
walton
continues to provide wonderful support
in the community
for people of all faiths and those
with none his words are thought
provoking
and heartfelt and he will be someone to
turn to when seeking help and care
so i invite the reverend green to sign
the declaration
of acceptance of office so
reverend greene
who swear by almighty god having been
elected to the office of civic chaplain
for north east derbyshire district
council
that i will be faithful and bear true
allegiance to her majesty queen
elizabeth
ii as and successors according to law
so help me god
okay
and then also to receive the civic stole
a few words invite to the reverend green
say a few words
mr chairman councillors officers of the
council
and members of the public i feel very
privileged to have been
invited to take this role as your new
chaplain
uh for the coming year and these strange
and challenging times i think any bit of
extra support we can get
is much appreciated and i'm very honored
these are days
of great challenge and wonderful
opportunity
we need to be approaching them with both
sensitivity and courage
and the discernment to know which to
exercise and when
these are also days of intense public
scrutiny of course where many things
that we do or say and don't do or say
uh end up in the social media before
sometimes we even
are aware of that kobe 19 has opened a
whole new world of experience
of that for me as we've been streaming
worship live over the past 14 months
and it's been shared across social media
platforms
and we've been blessed with a mixture of
very appreciative comments
love hearts and huggy emoticons and the
occasional angry face
but you don't need me to tell you that
not everyone will agree with everything
that you do or say or the decisions that
you make as a council
and not everyone will agree with every
decision you will occasionally encounter
an angry face and probably a one or two
real ones
as well but regardless i think we need
to strive for two things the first i
think is wisdom
the beginning of wisdom is this get
wisdom that's from the book of proverbs
i'll be praying for
wisdom for you all to make decisions
that are truly in the best interest
of the people that you serve and for
insight to see the needs and to be able
to connect with them
in real and important ways this is a
vital aspect of course of public service
as well as praying for wisdom for you
i'll be praying for a sense of unity
unity that's have its foundation and the
desire to serve you're here presumably
because you want to serve you are public
servants
the supreme example of that of course
for me has been remembered on good
friday as the one who had
power and authority laid it down for the
long-term good
of those he came to serve so i offer
myself to you as a
an extra means of support and
encouragement than someone
that you can have an impartial
conversation with if you need somebody
to talk to
or just generally praying for you and
holding before god the work of this
council
as it serves the people of the district
of northeast derbyshire
the world has changed in the life and
last year
dramatically it's been accelerated it
was already changing
i've done so at an alarming rate over
the last 14 months or so
i just want you to know that i'm here
for you i'm praying for you
and for the people that you serve and
that we would listen to them and hear
the needs
and address them with courage and faith
thank you thank you opengreen
thank you from trying item nine
appointments of civic cadets
the role of the civic cadet includes
attending public events such as
remembrance and civic services
each civic cadet brings a visible
association with local
cadet units of the armed forces
positive public perception and support
for charity fundraising
this year i'm delighted to announce the
appointment of
corporal callum sole warner of the
marine cadets
cadet first class lily wright of t.s
daney
c cadets and cadet oliver bates
of 331 squadron of the raf cadets i'm
delighted to see that cadets bates
and wright are with us this afternoon
good to see you both
each will be asked to sign the civic
cadets pledge and receive a badge for
their tunic
and certificate of appointment at a date
very soon
thank you item 10 appointment of cabinet
over to the leader pleased to announce
his cabinet for 2021
2022 councillor dale thank you chair
just to report that there's no changes
to cabinet um so it is as it was
for the previous year thank you
item 11 appointments to committees and
advisory groups
and hand over to council dale to propose
the conservative
nominations
thank you chet i'm not sure whether
nikki is able to
share the screen on this uh to talk that
through oh she's giving a thumbs up but
uh i can talk to the changes uh in terms
of committee places
um oh i think that's that's it for for
the uh
for the uh conservative nomination
certainly so
on the audit committee we'll be
replacing councillor william dayton with
councillor kevin tate
uh on these uh community scrutiny we'll
be replacing
uh councillor oscar gomez rini with and
uh council richard welton with
councillors mo potts
and william armitage uh on growth
scrutiny we'll be replacing
uh councillors diana ruff and
councillors uh councillor nick whitehead
with councillor philip wright and
councillor oscar gomez rini
and on licensing with uh the seat made
vacant by councillor
uh patricia bone uh we'll be uh
installing yourself as chair uh mr uh
sorry yourself uh council backers chair
uh and uh council richard welton as well
to replace
uh councillor huckabee on organization
scrutiny
uh again the vacancy uh created by
chancellor pat bone uh will be replaced
by
uh council richard welton uh and
councillor diana ruff will be replacing
council mo
potts uh and then in planning uh
councillor heather liggett will be
replacing directly
uh councillor uh huckabee as a sub
uh so council fb will be a southern
encounter uh have elegant will be on
planning committee
uh the joint ict committee uh
i'll be replacing councillor kevin tate
and councillor nick whitehead
uh with councillors jeremy kenyon and
paul parkin
and then finally with councillor kevin
bowen no longer on
member development working group uh i'm
inviting councillor pat
hancliff on to on to take that seat
i think that's all the changes on the
conservative nominations side of things
do we have a second of the conservative
nominations council cupid
thank you yeah happy to second that
thank you
and for the labour nominations
councillor barker
just to propose that would uh save time
yeah
yes and we've only made changes with the
planning committee and
swapped a couple of people around
substitutes so
that's printed are we happy with that
yes very happy thank you council reader
to second
labour nominations thank you liberal
democrat nominations councillor shipman
thanks chair and the only change we've
got is cancel hancock will be replacing
me on planning
um everything else is remaining as is
thank you and council hancock to second
thank you council hancock and
independence council for now
there's no change from last year
councillor cooper and myself will
continue on the
committees as stated thank you and
council cooper to second thank you
council cooper
so we're we now need to move to the vote
on block so can we have the poll please
final votes are in church i'm just going
to end the polling and share their
votes on the screen so the remote vote
is
unanimous for
[Music]
thank you so we moved to item 12
appointments of chairs and vice chairs
so
um for the conservative nominations
council dale
yeah thank you again um nikki may well
be able to
share the screen on this but we're
obviously as chair of the council that's
yourself
uh that's martin becker and vice chair
is council dyna roof
no changes to audits for communities
scrutiny i'm proposing
council mo potts as vice chair no
changes to growth
or the two licensing committees for
organization scrutiny and proposing
uh councillor angelique foster and
council richard welton as the
vice chair and for planning and
proposing council alan powell as vice
chair
and councillor heather liggett as vice
chair of standards
and that's that's it for the changes
from live so we need a secondary council
cupid
thank you council cupid are there any
other nominations for chairs by cs
council barca
thank you chair yeah we we uh we're
obviously disappointed looking at that
but
i would move that to pat kerry stays as
vice chair of standards and uh
cathy roush replace uh councillor uh
jane barry as last year of planning uh
i am disappointed but not surprised by
my other decision
uh and from my perspective personally
i think it's a backwards step for the
council i think it were a
a magnanimous gesture if you like first
time around and it's a shame
that that we've gone back well sailor
vee
thank you so do you have a second for
that those
nominations council reader thank you are
there any other nominations
council shipment i i just want to agree
with council marker here because i think
you know these are supposed to be
scrutiny committees um
i think you get the best scrutiny when
you've not bought by this
charge leading them um and i think that
it is a backwards step
uh i think it should be reform and
perhaps come back to the council a few
today so i'd like to say it's
definitely a backwards step here
well we've had them proposed in second
so i'm just asking uh
nikki we've got two nominations now all
the others uh are unopposed
apart from vice chair council kerry for
standards
vice chair council rouse for planning so
we will need to take a vote
on those two vice chair positions
i've put together a very quick poll um
so
the poll would state um the chairs and
vice chairs
as put in the the paper that was
submitted before
before the meeting um or as amended by
councillor barker so that would include
the changes for
the chairs and the vice chairs as stated
by council barco so if you're happy with
that chair i'll launch the poll
well if we can see the poll right so as
you can see
so if you're agreeing to the ones that
are circulated by the majority group
then you're voting as put
if you're um supporting the uh the two
vice chair
as put forward by council barker then
you're voting for as amended by
councillor barker
so please vote now
that's all the votes in chat so i'll
just end the polling there and
share the results and you'll see at the
right vote that it's 24
for as originally put and 19 as amended
thank you so commiserations to
councillor kerry and council rouse
and the nominations from the majority
group stand
so we move to item 13 scheme of
delegation so hand over to
mr sternberg please thank you chair
constitutionally the annual meeting is
required to approve the scheme of
delegation
this is before you any changes are shown
in the next report on the review
view of the council's constitution but
are relatively
relatively minor in nature thank you
chair
uh council dale to uh to move
yeah just to propose though that we
accept that thank you
do we have a seconder council cupid
thank you
are there any comments or questions
if not can we move to the vote please
please show the poll
please vote now
that's all the votes in chair that's
uh 41 4 with qr abstentions on the
remote vote
thank you so we now move to item 14
review of the council's constitution
so i invite mr sternberg monitoring
officer to present the report
thank you chair each year the standards
committee gives detailed consideration
to changes to the constitution to ensure
the rules within it are up to date
that the procedures within it are
effective and efficient and
reflect the wishes of members and the
law there are a number of
recommendations that are made for your
consideration
as detailed within appendix 1 to the
report the suggested changes include
raising the level
at which which requests for quotations
can be used in place of tenders
from 50 000 to 75 000 pounds
that is merely a change in the kind of
paperwork so instead of
requesting a full tender exercise
between 50 and 75 000
we'll now request uh make a request for
quote
which will have all the essential
details but isn't so bureaucratic
three new delegations to myself and my
role as monitoring officer
in reference to recruiting independent
persons that is the commencement of the
process to recruit independent persons
the six-month rule dispensations and
legal and housekeeping amendments to the
constitution
and some minor points of clarification
if agreed today
these changes will be incorporated into
the constitution
which will be republished as the 2021
version thank you
thank you so we need a mover for the
review so council armitage
uh thank you chair uh first of all i'd
like to thank the committee
and the officers uh for helping with
this review
and i would like to propose this review
to council thank you in a second to
please
council dale thank you any comments or
questions
if not can we move to the vote please so
we show the poll
yeah sorry council burkin sorry
thank you chair um i'd like to i'd like
to raise a point about appendix 3 the
clay cross town board
the terms of reference that have been
set there um i'm a little disappointed
that there are no
representatives of the working people
around clay cross
directly affected in this arena
by that i mean trade union
representatives the membership
lists local business and investors and
prominent members of civic faith
organizations and voluntary groups
and local sports teams i think it would
be helpful to
uh such an important uh project that the
uh
the council is involved in over there to
be more specific representation from
those people who represent the working
class in the area
so uh i would suggest that there should
be
an invitation to trade union
representatives on the body as well
please
i think my my first comment there in the
answer to that council burkin having
been part and parcel of setting up the
town board in the first place
is that the terms of reference of the
town borders set by a government
it's not it's not a local decision the
only um
leeway that there is is when we're
considering any subcommittees or working
groups
and that's where i know on the clay
crust town board they've tried to
accommodate
local people from clay cross and a
variety of others that aren't listed
in the ones set down by government so
the clay crosstown centre board has
worked hard
to include local people so we it
wouldn't be appropriate to
include it here because the terms of
reference for the board itself
is set down nationally
jareth i could just ask you then does
that the the um
the two items uh on 2.3 and 2.4
said that the board may comprise a
representative so
i would suggest that there's a bit of
discretion there for
each board to choose which areas it
wants to pick its members from
the the discretion is it the at a
working group level or sub group level
um i think yeah mr sternberg i think
um unless you want to add any comment to
that and announce it to council burkin
just if you wanted to look at this again
it could go back to the clay cross board
i think um if it's all out with you
council burkin you've made
the point and i think um
as i've already said the terms of
reference are set down by a national
body what we can do is um
feed that back to the town centre board
and we can incorporate your comments
in the feedback to the board so that
they are considering very carefully
the groups of people you're suggesting
in in working groups subcommittees and
that sort of thing to make sure that
everybody who should be included is
included
are you satisfied that's fine chair
thank you very much
thank you thank you council and are
there any other comments or questions
can we move them please to the vote
chair that's unanimously four on the
remote vote
thank you so much to item 15
appointments to outside bodies
so over to uh councillor dale for the
nominations please
thank you chad uh only two uh limited
changes here
uh the northwood group limited uh
councillor anthony hutchinson will be
joining councillor
nick whitehead and for the pear tree
friendship club uh we're replacing
councillor uh pat bone with
uh councillor mo pox that's it i think
thank you and counselor cupid please to
second
thank you any other comments or
questions about the
outside bodies that have been circulated
removed and seconded so can we move to
the boat please
chair the remote vote is 39-4 with four
abstentions
thank you that's carried in so item 16
the operation of urgency rules and
thresholds for king decisions
once again handing over to mrs sternberg
thank you chair
again constitutionally the annual
meeting is required to approve the
financial level for key decisions
in relation to the executive and the
operation the urgency rules
no change is proposed to these levels or
to the rules themselves but they are
there for your approval today
thank you thank you do we have a mover
and second to please
counselor dale and second by council
cupid are there any comments or
questions
council shipment yeah i just wanted to
ask you
you know on point a of this um threshold
where it says advise a of decisions
taken under emergency rules
within the council scrutiny rules would
this
take into account the issue we had not
so long ago where
decisions were taken under emergency uh
rules
and we didn't know about them but this
now encompassed that
or not
it does mr steward to respond first of
all i would dispute that nobody knew
about them what you're talking about is
the use of the emergency power and the
delegation scheme
that is for the head of paid service
this relates to executive and executive
decisions
and not giving not giving enough notice
because something's happened to cause it
to be urgent that kind of thing
the report's going to executive thank
you
all the comments all questions can we
move to the vote please
chair that's 42 votes for with one
abstention
okay that's carried so item 17 there are
no
urgent matters from myself as chair so
can i thank those who have attended the
annual meeting the cadets and the
representative ashgate hospice
and i'll now close the annual meeting of
the council
what i'm going to propose now is that we
have a short comfort break
um so that we can resume the business
meeting at
ten past four a short break and then
resume at 10 past four
thank you declare the annual meeting
closed
item one i'll get it right apologies for
absence
so we have apologies from council
huckabee
henry councillor holmes
cornwell barry
and i think there's one more
uh there was
yeah i have i have councillors barry
cornwall
holmes hill huckabee and kenya
yeah that's actually how can we forget
betty i know
how could we so thank you apologies
item two then declarations of interest
members are requested to declare the
existence and nature of any disposable
pecuniary interest
and or other interests not already on
their register of interest
in any item on the agenda and withdraw
from the meeting
at the appropriate time any declarations
none so we move to item public
public participation we've had no
questions received
under procedure rule number eight for
this meeting so move to item four
joint whistle-blowing policy so hand
over now to the
joint head of corporate governance and
monitoring mr sternberg please
thank you chair this is before you as
part of a regular review of the
whistleblowing policy
this year it's been reviewed and no
changes are proposed
in addition i can confirm that there
have been no instances of whistleblowing
reported to me
the recommendations are page seven page
seven thank you chair
thank you so we do need to propose in
secondary so
proposing council mark foster
uh thank you chair yes uh thank you for
the offer to the officers for the work
they've done this
and i'd like to move the recommendations
as set out in the report
council foster and seconded by council
dale
thank you are there any comments or
questions
none so in that case can we move to the
vote please
this is to agree the current policies
fit for purpose
chair that's all in favor thank you so
much carried
so item five growth strategy so over to
the cabinet member
for growth council renick thank you
chair
i just wanted to take this opportunity
to give you an all an update on the
district's growth strategy
and that we recognize the importance of
economic growth
to the overall well-being and prosperity
of our residents
the strategy itself still in draft form
it's 90 done has been
90 done for some time however during
kobe we did present
a recovery strategy as an interim
document which highlighted the
significant amount of work that councils
delivered over the
past 12 months if you remember some 40
projects of varying scale scope and size
and we still um wanted to make sure that
we were aligned with our partner
organizations growth recovery strategies
that they've all been
updated and those key partners include
dubstep county council
d2n2 martin p district and uh derbyshire
envisioned damage to name but a few
i have already presented the council the
to the council the individual
visitor economy and skills strategy
which forms part of the overall growth
strategy
and we're now working on the the
important and final strand which is the
assets and um
investment strategy which includes
mapping out valuing evaluating all of
our assets and major sites so we can
take a more strategic long-term view
ensure we can maximize our investment
potential and that's
a huge piece of work that's ongoing but
i'd like to just the council to know the
progress to date
so quite simply our vision is that we
want northeast derbyshire to be
a prosperous sustainable and diverse
business friendly district
and our aim is that this council and its
partners will endeavor to support
growth at a community level providing
guidance
advice and facilities to support our
businesses
but we also need to maximize the public
and private investment locally and
indeed
encouraging with investors who are
aligned with our vision
and also building on our wealth of
natural cultural
leisure and heritage assets in a
sustainable way
which means being mindful of our carbon
footprints increasing
use and development of modern technology
and ensuring equality
and inclusive activity with all that we
do
so the growth strategy itself focuses on
key priority areas eight of them which
is
business support and engagement
employment and skill support
the visitor economy town centre
regeneration
inward investment uh
royal agricultural economy and the
assets and investment strategy which
will be added shortly
and as you will note from our action
plan we've started our plan work on
projects in all these key areas but to
ensure success of our strategy it's
imperative that we are aligned
with the government's modern industrial
strategy which is entitled building a
britain fits the future and that sets
out
the government's plan for transforming
the country's economy and bringing about
new growth and more importantly
productivity
the government sets out five foundations
of productivity
they're ideas or innovation people which
includes up skilling
better jobs better earning power for all
infrastructure with the physical digital
transport be more accessible business
environment itself and place
sort of place regeneration and you might
have noticed i've taken a rather
prudent and pragmatic approach in
developing our strategy
and the reason why that's important to
be aligned with government and that of
our partners
is it's the best chance we have applying
for and drawing down funds
for our um anything to do with the
funding opportunities that might come
our way
um i'd like to reassure you that a lot
of work has already been undertaken by
staff and officers across
many departments supporting local
businesses and we've been
praising one of the best performing
councils for getting kobe support grants
out in record time and i'd like to take
opportunity to thank officers and staff
both in the economic growth team
and the departments for going above and
beyond during this time
and i'm also pleased that a number of
our key areas that we've been trying to
address
and deliver are areas that government
and other partners have also moved up
their agenda such as town center
regeneration
and tourism in fact this government's
leveling up agenda has a key aim to
ensure
rebalancing of prosperity throughout the
country and i'm proud to say that this
council
is at the forefront of this agenda
having just been awarded 24.1 million
pound per clay cross as part of the
government's 3.6 billion pounds town
fund
and that was on top of the half a
million that we've already received last
summer so
you know in northeast derbyshire we are
over the business
we are well underway with a clown the
clay crosstown deal plan
we've already started some demolition
from the accelerator fund
we've finished some leisure culture and
arts projects within the town
and we're investigating a number of
energy demonstrated
demonstrated projects across clay cross
we're also involved with one public
estate we're moving at pace looking at
regeneration of
kilometers in eckington town we'll be
developing new plaster plans for drone
fields
we're progressing the avenues site
infrastructure issues
we've now got a dedicated business
advisor employed by the district giving
one-to-one advice to our businesses we
also have a intern
visitor economy officer who's doing
great work in reaching out to tourism
businesses
and helping us launch a new tourism app
we've rolled out a number of job fairs
we've helped with tv writing and we've
also
done a number of webinars aimed at
improving digital skills to local
businesses
we've delivered kickstart and
apprenticeship workshops we've launched
buyer local and shop happy initiatives
and we've had support from the
environmental health team supporting our
business to return
to business in a cobia safe manner so
much has been done
at too much for to mention here and much
more yet to come
but a huge thanks for to all the
dedication commitments
and then i hope that was a useful update
this
strategy is a living document so i look
forward to presenting
the final part of this strategy in due
course
i'm very happy to take any questions but
would like to move recommendations
one to three to know the contents of
this report and the
restricted to date and also dedicated
authority to
the director of economic growth myself
as a portfolio holder to just make some
um non-substantive amendments to
complete this report
thank you so um thank you for proposing
so we need a second uh council
hutchinson
yes if i could second that
thank you thank you council hutchinson
thank you and any comments or questions
council marker
thank you chair yes it is a it is a
lovely
it is a good document there's no two
ways about it uh
there's a lot of work going into there
and uh
as i know being on the the growth
scrutiny committee
we are we have looked at this uh and
there's a lot of good work
the the the point i'd make and i'm sure
you'd expect me to
is that a lot of this is on the back
that of the work that we'd already
started when
when we were in in control because
it were obvious without growth in this
area because of the government
cutbacks with their central government
grants
the only way to survive is is to have
growth in
in our area so we can collect business
rates and all that
stuff so it is good work uh
and i i'm sure that that security
committee
and others will keep a check on the uh
the action plan and and we keep to some
of those
targets because
i can't argue there's a lot of good work
in there
and and similarly i still make the point
that the clay cross down fund
came on the back of the one public
estate work that
that we started and i hope that we get a
similar thing for killer marsh and
eckington
going forward but uh i think it's
a joint uh achievement a lot of this
uh and and i i don't know where i don't
know if i should be saying this with
her and all that malarkey but we are uh
it is a political arena i think we
deserve some of the credit as well as
council market um i'm going to go to
council dale and then council birkin
thank you chair um i think we we've
disagreed hundred times before over
over over what led to the town deal
council barca so i won't i won't
reiterate that and
and clearly we're always going to
recognize when uh
you know when uh officers have done a
lot of a lot of background work and
uh and to an extent uh what previous
administrations have done but for me the
big difference here
is that the the last growth plan and
strategy that that we had as
a as a council wasn't a growth strategy
it was a housing growth strategy
and the big difference here for me is
that this is a growth strategy that that
contains all the relevant strands
for the whole of the economy in in
northeast derbyshire it's got the
tourism covered off it's got employment
and skills as part of it's got
regeneration as part of it and actually
for me representing quite a rural award
i'm really pleased that it's got
agriculture and and farming represented
in that document so it really is
for me a much more comprehensive growth
strategy
and i'd just like to thank council
renick and all of the officers and the
team who have
uh put in a huge amount of work to make
this happen it's clearly not finished
yet
there's been more work to do as as
councillorenic said uh and obviously
once once it's in place there'll still
be work to do in terms of implementing
the things that are in it but i just
think it's a it's a really good piece of
work
and just want to offer my congrats to
council renick and the rest of the
officers for all the work on it
thank you thank you thank you council
burkin thank you chair
um one thing that struck me as i've read
through the document
uh a lot of uh good stuff that's that's
coming out there
i i i have to admit uh but looking
through the action plan there are
several
instances where he's talking about the
resources required
are highlighting financial allocation
for consultancy costs
this is to cover uh obtaining business
advice
looking at appropriate business spaces
looking at undertaking a skills audit
uh looking at evidence to support the
businesses and site and marketing
research
the problem that i have with that is
that these consultants
as we're well aware of through local and
national
uh situations a lot of public money is
spent
uh on their uh on their involvement
uh i would just like to suggest that you
consider
using the local universities around
the report quite correctly uh identifies
five or five or six local universities
that will be
invited to get involved or are being
involved
and i would suggest that some of this
research activity
that consultants have been considered
for could be undertaken by students
and their supervisors at these
universities
to undertake these investigations as
part and parcel of their studies it
would be
good direct qualification or work and
work experience for them
and would enable the authority to to get
advice and support
without being too costly in the long run
thank you chair
thank you councilman just so you know
councilman i'll come to you at the end
so that you can round off with any
comments or answers to
questions poised hey council watching
son
thank you chair yeah i too would like to
thank and congratulate councillor inik
and i'd seen for this comprehensive
growth strategy uh the strategy shows
our intentions for growth in our
district and she has delivered
in great detail this report to encourage
and support new and existing families
and businesses to grow in or choose
northeast derbyshire as a home with all
its natural beauty and the promise of
regeneration with our towns and villages
this report shows our intentions come
and visit work and learn in northeast
derbyshire
come and live here come and play because
we have plenty to offer for you to
explore
and i'm sure carolyn you won't want to
rest on your laurels and you'll be
constantly tweaking improving this
strategy so congratulations and onwards
and upwards with northeast derbyshire
thank you thank you council for now
oh yeah just following on from other
people really i think it's a good report
i think there's some
really good challenges and some great
focus there for growth
but my question would be have you got
the support
financially to do the things that you're
planning
in the resort this is required more
often than not
it talks about financial contribution
and i just wondered whether that had
been costed
and budgeted for in the next uh next
period
thank you council shipment thank you
the thing that got me when i was reading
this i mean it's it's a good report it's
got a lot of stuff in it but what i
found was missing
was the lack of mention of the
environment and the actions
oh are we actually because i mean when
we passed the motion
or the strategy story two years ago it
was mentioned that it was going to be
kind of entwined with
you know all the decision making in the
council and promoting it within
businesses and
and all that but i'm literally i've
searched the document and it doesn't
even mention
environment in the actions at all but i
just wondered if there's any intention
to kind of
have that joined up thinking with the
environmental aspects as well as
encouraging businesses here
and potentially new green businesses in
the district
thank you any other comments or
questions
if not council relics reply
thank you chair um right on the on the
consultants
there's not very much consultancy work
just to when it
mentions quite a lot of partners and
you're right in terms of university are
definitely a first port of call in fact
a lot of the work on the visitor economy
was done by an intern that happens to
be doing an mba and she's actually lives
in eckington
and she's doing quite a lot of work and
actually she's superb she's current
she's young she's
she's she's making our tourism visual
economy strategy looks like something
that
another generation would like to be part
of so the
consultants are a little bit at the
moment through the montgomery estate
and the clay cross deal but at the
moment that's the only consultants we've
got
in terms of cost yes um obviously part
of the investment in asset strategy is
looking at that you know we
we raise a million pounds a year from
our assets could we do more
could we sell our sets could we buy
reinvest into
into other parts of the district that's
all to be decided and
you know that's maybe where we build a
bit of a chest of investments for
the latest strategies um but also is
looking at the um
funding streams we've got something to
apply for uh
in the um in another fund that's coming
our way
we've shown we're successful in terms of
24.1 million
million pounds for the town deal yeah
i'll you know
well i can argue councillor barker about
this you know for
forever um at the end of the day the
past growth strategies were really just
housing strategies there was nothing
embedded
in growth and you know if you'd done
that job properly
in your in your term with those embedded
skills within
their businesses now we're going to
start and hit the ground running
and i'm immensely proud of the
industrial strategy that
our government has actually put forward
and you know are quite rightly of course
behind it to that because that's where
the future funding will come in terms of
growing the rest of our
of our local district um in terms
of the i mean i i
it reflects the council's shipment i
think council hickey wants to come in
but
um if you've surprised you've asked that
because it means that our fourth page is
that you know that the cost-cutting
themes
were about equality included inclusivity
uh
using you know obviously modern
technology and digital solutions and
development of increased uses of carbon
and low technology you know we've got
three demonstrated projects we're
looking at at clay cross
which could be potentially huge for this
for this area some of them will be
transformational
um and there's a you know we've talked
already about the
10 10-point plan for a green industrial
revolution again that our government set
out the points
that they're all in here on page eight
and nine so there's quite a lot in their
uh cancer shipment um in terms of the
action plan
you know obviously we'll have to that's
going to be developed
more in time but there's definitely a
huge part of this growth plan
he's going to be green growth um i'll
end it there because i think lee hickey
would like to come in on that
if i could that's i'm sorry but you were
rounding off councillor renick
the debate has happened um so
thank you anyway lee but um it's been
proposed and seconded so can we move to
the vote
okay i'll end the vote there and share
the results on the screen uh
37 versus four one against with two
abstentions
thank you that's carried so item six
independent person recruitment
this is in your supplementary agenda
items that have been
sent to you so i now invite to mrs
sternberg to present the report
thank you chair as members are aware
from a previous council report we have
been through a
recruitment exercise for a new
independent person
we had such a good response that i have
decided to recommend
the appointment of two independent
persons giving us three in total
this will give us considerable
flexibility and resilience
particularly in relation to parish
council complaints
the report doesn't give details of the
individual so i will give you brief
details of their cvs
david richardson is a resident of
hasland he currently works for the
university of derby supporting students
with study skills
and to access learning resources however
the majority of his career was spent as
an investigator for the local government
ombudsman
from which he retired in 2015. this
background enabled david to exceed the
criteria for the role in terms of his
experience
and an understanding of local government
in interview david answered all
questions to a standard which was either
satisfactory
or exceeded the required level in doing
so he demonstrated
strong communication skills and an
understanding of ethical standards
he also demonstrated an excellent
understanding of the analytical
approach needed in dealing with
complaints and
in determining whether breaches of codes
of conduct have occurred
the other recommendation is amanda
orchard who lives in horton
cambridgeshire
and who until the pandemic had most
recently worked as a self-employed
part-time marketing and communications
consultant
she's also a non-executive director at
the registration council
of clinical psychologists in recent
years amanda has taken on a number of
voluntary roles
including independent person at three
other local authorities
membership of remuneration and
disciplinary panels
at various organizations and lay
membership of two groups in the
in the health care sector while her
previous experience as an independent
person and in disciplinary matters
helped her to meet the criteria we were
looking for her answers
interview exceeded expectations in
several areas
amanda demonstrated an excellent
understanding of ethical frameworks on
the skills required in assessing
complaints and allegations of misconduct
in addition she showed a good insight
into the need for fairness
in decision making together with
excellent communication skills
the recommendations are in the softly
supplementary pack as the chair said at
page three
and i would also just a tag onto that
i'd like to send a
letter of thanks to the retiring
independent person on behalf of the
council
thank you thank you so to move the
recommendations council armitage
yes thank you chair yes i would like to
move this recommendation
about the independent person recruitment
and again thank you sarah sternberg for
carrying out the necessary
interviews so i'd like to
move this recommendation thank you and
seconded by council dale thank you are
there any comments or questions
[Music]
apart from the hope that these two
independent persons won't
be very busy
um okay no comments or questions can we
move to the vote please
share the remote vote is unanimous thank
you
so item seven there have been no
questions submitted under procedure rule
nine point two for this meeting so move
to item eight
to consider any motions from members
under procedure rule number ten
originally three motions were submitted
various businesses and people during the
year during the
the kovid crisis that we've had but
there are a lot and i think all of us
will have
a significant number in our wards of
people who have fallen through the
cracks
um we've had um and in the company i
work for we had one
one chap who was taken on first of march
last year
um obviously he was still in training
when covered hit um
we were he was couldn't be furloughed
because his start date was too late
and we couldn't keep him because he
wasn't trained to be able to do the job
sufficiently
that's one of a lot of examples there
are a lot of people who've
actually started their own businesses
during the course of this they've fallen
through the cracks as well and through
through the whole countries we know
there are absolutely millions of people
who are not actually getting the support
that they really should be
so the basis behind this is to actually
look at one of the trials uh as is to
look at northeast derbyshire being
proactive
taking up a trial for the uh univer
universal income um to actually
set a baseline so that these people
aren't waiting for universal credit to
uh
to to kick in um some of them quite a
few weeks
they've got no income at all um
obviously doesn't say that the the
example i gave earlier
we have someone who doesn't have the
provision to have savings behind them
because they haven't been working long
enough
and the system is failing those and it's
failing them massively
so on that basis i'm actually putting
this through in the hope that
northeast derbyshire will be proactive
that we will address that shortfall
we know there are people falling through
the cracks we can't claim otherwise
but let's have to try and do something
about it
thank you chair
thank you councillor hancock and to
second council shipment
i'll second lecture and reserve my right
to
thank you so any comments or questions
about the motion
council dale
i was going to be a gentleman and let
councillor barker go first but i'll
i'll happily go first um just
thanks uh for the motion being put on
the agenda but
on behalf of the conservative group i
don't think that we can support this
um and it's a few matters of principle
really that we don't
don't agree with uh universal basic
income
on i think the first point to make is
that it's an extremely blunt instrument
fundamentally you start from the basis
that absolutely everyone will receive
money from the state regardless of their
relative wealth so
effectively this motion at its heart
wants to give someone like richard
branson
the same amount of public money as
someone who's on the breadline and
struggling to support themselves and
their family
and i just think that that's
fundamentally wrong i think that the
role of the state is to step in
and support those who are most in need
and not to give handouts to some of the
richest people in the country
and we would actually literally be
redistributing quite limited public
money
and taxpayer money and using it to line
the pockets of those who just simply
don't need it
um so i don't really understand the the
the the
support for ubi from uh the more
left-leaning
parties because you know they talk about
fairness and i just don't see that this
is a fair way of
doing anything at all um obviously the
support by the government throughout the
kobe pandemic has been extremely
generous i don't think anyone can uh
can argue with that but it has been done
on on the basis of a short-term approach
it's never been
um it's never been supposed to be a
long-term
uh thing and that's we've got to bear
that in mind because there are huge
costs
associated with it and it's clearly
going to have
an impact on the country for many years
to come um
fundamentally ubi would just be hugely
expensive
and and add to the national debt at a
time when it's already extremely high
because of covered
and for my from my perspective it's
morally wrong
in my opinion to to heat more debt onto
future generations to
to have to pay it off and i know that
that
you know uh those on the on the on the
left of the spectrum would argue that
uh debt is overstated national debt is
overstated as an issue
uh but i just don't think you can ignore
national debt i think it has a huge
impact on the country
there have been times during the last 10
years where we've been spending more
on servicing the interest on our
borrowing than we have been on
you know vital services like policing
for example and that's just not a
sustainable way to run a country
and nor is it an appropriate use of
taxpayers money and i suppose the final
third point i would like to make is that
based on what i've read i don't believe
that trials of ubi and other places
where it has been
uh tried about found to be effective i'm
aware of
a trial in finland uh and actually from
what i've read
uh it didn't help people to find
employment if anything actually
it it it made the employment stagnated
and
carried on so i'm not really sure that
it would actually be of any benefit
anyway
so on behalf of the conservative group
um i think we'll be voting against this
motion
um on those grounds thank you chair
thank you council barker thank you chair
uh yeah we've had a discussion in our
group about this and
and in principle uh to be honest i don't
know a lot about it
our the universal basic income
what it entails or whatever but uh we we
can support it the the
the actual what it's asking for the
council to resolve
uh is is not massive whether it amounts
to anything
it'll be a question i think or our group
believes that that rock you know we
we all agree i think we i think you've
said it alex that
people should you know have a minimum
income and we shouldn't have anybody
uh below certain levels of several
income but a lot more research needs to
be done into the concept i think of this
this universal basic income uh i don't
know
it could lead to other things i've heard
that
nationally you know it could replace the
national insurance thing you know this
so there's there's lots of issues around
it uh
but we we can we'll support it
but but i'd like personally like a lot
more about it
what we did is ask him for a trial so
we'll see and and and i accept some of
the arguments
uh obviously i don't agree with with
some of the the things
uh bought
going forward there's some big decisions
to made at central government
any other comments or questions
council shipment thanks chair um
it's worth pointing out that this
obviously this motion is not
prescriptive it's not
on the type of ubi model it needs to be
it would be very much open to welcoming
one that was put forward by
government um just to use your
richard branson they just used a
believer of the council's richard
branson example
the taxpayer already does subsidize
multiple people through subsidizing low
incomes through tax breaks
the government already does this what
this would do
though is it would give everybody
a a secure level of income but the
numbers
because wealth is so concentrated in
this country
the amount of people that would actually
be affected in terms of you paying them
money that they don't actually need it's
very minimal
in terms of across the across the whole
country
so more people would benefit from this
system because it puts more money in
their pockets they can spend
it will help the growth strategy we've
just been discussing because people are
more likely to spend that money
that creates more taxes it's about a
whole wider system
than let's just and put into some money
in people's pockets
it does drive growth if you can give
people money to spend
um and you know like i say it's not
prescriptive this motion
it's very much wanting to welcome to
northeast armature a trial
whatever that model looks like whatever
form
you're saying will welcome looking at
you know basic income a different way
uh because like as counseling oh
universal credit
although it's in principle a good system
it does have its flaws in that people
aren't getting paid quick enough
and there's and then there's the uh
criteria which people have to qualify to
get it
and it creates problems in itself and
that will drive poverty through
northeast orbit
so i think we actually need to prove
this motion
uh and welcome their trial don't forget
it's a trial we're not saying
you know we've supported if the trial
hasn't failed yeah this is welcoming
looking at something a different way
and trial in it to see if it works thank
you
council luis
well thank you chairman um this is an
interesting
uh idea however i have to say on balance
i couldn't support
the concept um i'm not sure where um
uh council hancock and um and everyone
thinks that they're going to get the
money to be able to afford to do
this in the first place and why north
east derbyshire should be some kind of
pilot for this
um just doesn't make any sense i'm sure
if you were to take ask that question of
the taxpayers of derbyshire should we
subsidize
everybody in the county you'll get a
fair percentage you'll say yes and
you'll get a third percentage to say
well i got a cotton picking minute
who's going to pay for all of this is it
going to come out of my taxes
we are working in an economy that
requires
people to pay taxes and
it requires a buoyant economy which is
something we had prior to covet 19
at this moment in time we just do not
have that level of
income to sustain this and this is a
matter of principle as well
people out there are working hard people
out there are really struggling at the
moment we know that and the government
has really stepped up providing what has
been an absolutely critical safety net
that's been built on the back of a
buoyant economy
and people paying their taxes and that's
what should be funding these things
we have um universal credit and we've
talked about that
on multiple occasions north east
derbyshire we know it's had
some teething problems as it were
through um sort of its growing pains but
it is now embedded it is now
functioning the way that it was intended
and is doing um rather well in that
and it provides a safety net and the
safety net is important for society
but we can't have is a crutch for
society and that is what you're
suggesting
um i can't support this at all um i
don't think
and um yeah as i say i don't know where
you think the money is going to come
from for this but
uh you can try planting that monetary
any comments or questions
council renick yes it's not as nice as
the thing it sounds to do you know we do
already have
some universal basic um income in terms
of pension and child support and
you know that's you know they're already
systems that are set up you know that's
where you should be lobbying government
if you you know the increases if that's
what you think will make a difference
but from my point of view i think you're
just looking at staffing resources i
just think that's a
huge ask for for our district council to
be involved in in that at this time
and uh for that reason i i can't support
it either
thank you i think there's no other
comments or questions
so i'm going to invite councillor
hancock to
have his right to reply thank you chair
um to pick up on on council louis's um
comments i think first
is probably uh i i'm not sure kind of
where the concept comes that it's an
expensive system to run
ultimately every single one of us in
this meeting has a tax code
so all of us to some degree get some
benefit from the state
um in whatever form it takes the key
crooks
which is where i differ with counsellor
dale i
understand what he's saying and
councillor renek made a similar comment
um about about the uh the benefit system
that we have
and that we got through the teething
problems the reality is
there is still a significant waiting
time for people
who become unemployed to actually
getting paid any money
now for a lot of us that is probably
cushionable
for many people it isn't
literally people some people are living
one week to the next if they have that's
then suddenly got to wait
five weeks for anything to come that is
actually crippling
and that is that is what this this kind
of process is designed
to take out so that there isn't that
element
of people struggling and going without
um in terms of why north east derbyshire
we are
hopefully a progressive council i would
have thought we have our residents
interests at heart
and to be truthful i would have thought
it would be something that we would have
bitten hands off
to actually present and say let's try
this we know the economy's got to
reshape somewhere along the lines
as i say it's that there's this illusion
that somehow it's hugely costly but the
reality
is we all get a tax allowance we all get
or they're about roughly 12 and a half
thousand
tax free each year admittedly we have
enough insurance things like that
change it so we all get something we
just need to make sure that
it is there and payable for people from
day one if suddenly they find themselves
out of work through no fault of their
own
through a system which as we know the
pressure that has been put on the dwp
and hmrc this past 12 months
has been horrendous through no fault of
their own they have been slow in dealing
with stuff
anyways when suddenly a workload doubles
and so people have been waiting even
longer
so this is really to whilst yes it does
benefit everyone it is there to protect
the absolute
poorest in society i think we have a
responsibility to do that
thank you chair thank you council
hancock so uh
we move to the vote on the motion now
proposed by council hancock so could we
have the poll please
so whether to approve the motion is for
against or abstain vote now please
chair the results should be on screen
with 16 votes for
25 against with one abstention
thank you the motion has been lost and
so we move to uh motion c
proposed by councillor reader o2 please
council reader
thank you chair and uh my
congratulations martin on you becoming
the chair
thank you okay i know how hard a job it
is so
okay so obviously members have got the
report in front of them you'll have had
time to read
the motion that's in the report so i
just want to emphasize that i'm
seeking cross-party support for this
motion
and it's looking uh for you know
supporting including the wider community
and uh we've got to recognize that the
government target of 2050
the the evidence is showing that it's
shifted
we really do need to make some much more
strong you know stronger and uh action
and and take it much much sooner um
the climate ecology bill is is an
important piece of of work that's going
to
absolutely put the emphasis on getting
that work
done much much much sooner so for those
reasons i'm
moving this motion chair thank you
council reader do we have a second uh
i believe councillor jones council jones
yes kelsey jones
yes i want to second this motion and
can i reserve the right to reply of
course thank you council jones so
um are there any comments or questions
about the motion
council hancock
thank you chair um the only comment i
would make i absolutely agree with
everything council reader has just said
i'm fully supporting of that motion
um it's the dates are shifting and we
need to really get a move on
to try and address these issues so fully
behind you tracy
thank you council pickering thank you
chair
um i'm talking in support of this motion
her climate the climate emergency
is probably one of the most important uh
things that we've got to deal with both
locally and
nationally at this moment in time and
and i think probably nobody would
disagree with that as this council has
already
supported a climate emergency um
and this goes a step further and i think
a lot of us will recognize
um that the government's been a bit slow
about it
paul um and is not um
working as fast as local authorities are
and some other people
would like to see and this has been uh
put together the climate uh an
ecological emergency
bill um it's been drafted by a number
of people including scientists academics
lawyers
and activists and and other people that
probably know better than me and some of
us hear about it
to try and uh get the government to move
more quickly um really um
to strengthen the climate change act to
ensure that britain
has a comprehensive strategy to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions and restore the
um and restore our natural world
and uh some of the unique things about
the climate and ecological emergency
bill
um is that it requires the minister of
state to have
a definitive roadmap and rather than
just lurching from one thing to another
to have a cohesive
plan um that's actually taking more
rapid climate action
the government's still stuck in the
scientific advice of 2050
and you know things have changed a piece
the evidence has changed
we need to change our minds we need to
bring that forward to 2030 if not
sooner um to do the things that we need
to do
um and a quote from the guardian um
says that the government's 2050 net zero
target gives us
just greater than 50 chance of limiting
global heating to 1.5
and we'll need to make rapid and far
more reaching unprecedented changes in
all aspects
of society to do that and that's what
this climate in
an ecological emergency bill requires
with that
roadmap the other um quite unique thing
in that is it talks about the citizens
assembly and while it's quite right that
elected
uh legislators um formulate the policy
and decide the policy
it's also very important i think where
they gather that information from
and currently the government's gathering
that information from its own appointed
scientists who are not changing the
advice from 2050
other scientists and other people that
know who would make up that citizen's
assembly
would bring a wealth of knowledge and
experience to inform
more rapid more rapid action
um on that um
it's we've asked in the recommendations
that we
let the public know and that we contact
our
local mp the public need to know because
public consultation
is vitally important and as i said while
we've made a bit of a good start locally
with our
climate change action group the public
locally are asking for that
and that client that as a citizens
assembly would be
important our local mp i've been in
correspondence with
has or very kindly written back um
to say that at this moment in time you
won't be supporting that
um and i think we need to apologize for
interrupting councillor pickering just
to advise you you have one minute left
i can finish in one minute chair thank
you um you know he's
he's still stuck with the government's
plan for 2050 and that needs to change
we need to convince him on that
um and he doesn't like the idea of the
citizens
um assembly but as i've already said we
need to widen the
knowledge base from the governments and
pick scientists
and to to where to where we get a more
rounded
uh knowledge base so with that chair
i'll be supporting this motion
thank you council pickering and
apologies for interrupting you just
advising you of the time yes thank you i
appreciate that thank you
thank you council government
thank you chair um will not be
supporting this motion
the last time that i checked we're a
district council not the united nations
and as far as i'm aware we don't have an
aviation
section in the council and the only
shipping that we're involved in
is packets and parcels unless you count
the chesterfield canal
so our residents elected us to run a
district council
not be a political lobbying group and it
is distressing to see the council's time
being wasted
in such a manner i do also wonder
if the mover is aware that there already
has been
a citizen's assembly looking at this
free issue
and they reported last year now you can
read about this
at climate assembly dot uk
i do however completely agree that
climate change is a very serious issue
and it's our duty to take care of our
part of addressing climate change which
is why we will continue
to focus our remit and not be distracted
by posturing this is why we're investing
millions of pounds
in everything from one of the most
advanced
low-carbon pools in eckington to
millions on external wall installation
for our most inefficient council houses
not only reducing their carbon footprint
but providing some of our least well-off
residents
with warmer homes at the cost less to
heat
so we're also working with the county
council on a variety of county-wide
strategies
ranging from procurement of large-scale
housing improvements
to our thanks a ton program to encourage
residents to take the many small steps
that will reduce our district's carbon
footprint
there are so these are the actions that
we were elected
to take the lead on and that will remain
our focus
so i urge the council to reject this
motion thank you chair
thank you council jones
yes um
i'm not sure that this is about making
political points
we all agree uh that the council has
gotten an emergency about
climate change and we agree with the
um the bill that's coming in but what
i'd like to say
is that the council needs to make the
public more
aware of how climate change will affect
all of us
so that actions needed will be fully
supported
everyone must be on board to understand
the things that
are crucial to beginning
to beginning reductions of carbon by
individuals and working places
councils and governments one great thing
that has come out of the pandemic
it has proved with evidence
that it can be dramatically cooked the
carbon emissions
and the environment has been improved
now we've seen clearer skies we've seen
the greenery more animals coming back
why didn't work before
lots of things are happening just
because of climate change and the
actions that they're taking
it's not that um hard to imagine is
building on that
and when we're looking at looking at
20 50 it seems a hell of a long time
we know we can do it we've seen it in
action
we can persuade people that this is the
way forward
people will take it on board it's about
their children and the grandchildren
and i think we can we work towards
the 2030s the early 2030s
and that is about reality and
we've already seen that so i would like
you to support this please
thank you council jones council lewis
thank you very much indeed chairman and
uh i forgot to congratulate you the
first time i spoke so i'll take
the opportunity to do so uh this time um
congratulations on taking
the chair of the council i've known you
for a good number of years
i think you'll do a um a sterling job of
it and
certainly do a sterling job of keeping
us all in in order
yeah and thank you councillors i have
included that in your five minutes
thank you um
um i have to disagree with what council
pickering said i think we have taken
very much in the uk
a key lead um uk government in
particular
um uh under the premiership of boris
johnson has been
um quite startling in the way that it
has responded to the
the climate issues that we are
globally uh facing and it has taken a
very much a strong lead
and britain has to be fair taken a
strong lead over a good number of years
since 1990 we've reduced our emissions
by
over 40 percent you compare that to the
29
over the same period as uh germany you
begin to see this emerging
pattern and that's right across the
various administrations as well as
up to uh up to this point there are some
key issues uh
with uh the 2050 versus the 20 30 day i
think the evidence is robust
and it is uh it is included in there i
disagree with the principles around the
um
uh uh independent citizens assemblies
uh we are elected members um as is the
government as is the governments
around the world the united nations
playing a key role
ipcc which advises governments um
again draws its information
right across from all of academia to
make
its informed decisions and saying that
um
you know academia isn't playing a role
is utterly wrong
in that we need to bring people with us
i've said this on multiple occasions
before
uh on the journey to decarbonizing
asking people to uh give up their cars
tomorrow their diesels their
petrol cars they want to do it but not
everybody's going to do it or be able to
afford to do it um
with rapidity so it's incredibly
important that we recognize that
and work with the pace that's currently
set that being said
we should be doing all that we can to
decarbonize as quickly as possible
and we need to decarbonize um with
the uh the sector uh the industry um
that's out there to make sure that
they're decarbonizing um as well and
um in that vein we have set out
in fact um the derbyshire 2030
climate pledge and hopefully i can get
this read out to you uh quickly enough
uh to be included within my five minutes
chair so i hope you'll allow me some
grace in this first few seconds
um so the derbyshire 2030 climber
pledged harvest conservatives commit to
drastically cutting carbon emissions in
the county by 2030
with the aim of being net zero by 2050
in line with ambitious targets set by
the government and the ipcc
we will do this by working with our
communities other local councils with
industry and academia
to ensure a fair and sensible transition
to lower
and zero carbon technologies and to grow
the county economy by facilitating a
green industrial revolution
locally to achieve this we will commit
to growing the local skills base
and creating high quality jobs for
people of all ages
and investing in communities reminding
council lewis we are in purder
for anything that slips into county
thank you
thank you chair i was just going to say
this well i was going to say that first
please okay well i think it applies to
the whole county
and um and it's about doing our level
best to reduce
carbon emissions uh by 2030 and to
ensure that we
um also um hold the destruction of
important natural habitats
and create new new habitats across the
uh um um
the district as well and i think i'll uh
end it on that chair and i'm sure any
party that's out there
who wants to join us in us in that
endeavor i think that's a much stronger
a much more focus
locally focused way of doing it thank
you chairman
thank you council lewis thank you are
there any other comments or questions
counselor shipment yeah i mean
we've just heard a lot of waffles to say
that you don't want to listen to the
residents that we're supposed to be
representing to be quite honest
because ultimately whether it's a
citizen assembly or some kind of makeup
of assistance
we're consulting with residents it's
something that we should be welcoming
not saying well that's below our pay
grade we shouldn't be consulting those
that elected us
once we're elected i find that
astonishing that any council would
actually sit on this live stream and
tell people
to be quite honest um i will be
supporting this notion
it seemed you know we need to be
ambitious to be quite honest the
target's a target you don't necessarily
have to achieve that target but if you
aim for it you might just get there a
bit quicker than you would if you set it
20 years ahead
um so i yeah i'll be supporting this
motion
uh i think it's you know let's just
support it i just i i honestly find it
as long as you know what we've just said
i'm just just reminding you know council
shipment that
it isn't waffle it's everyone's
considered opinion
council council marker thank you chair
i wasn't i wasn't going to to join in on
this see there
it's peda and all that stuff well sorry
i've just been correct it's not perfect
it's election period
election period yes we've got election
period yeah sorry
sorry i apologize it's the election
theory
but um i'm a bit we we council shipment
i don't see a problem with this motion
really
it's it's just asking to support a bill
fair enough it might be a national thing
but but we are
a political body that can lobby on
certain things
and uh and i don't see our deferring to
me
colleagues that that can put this
argument better than me
which they have but i don't see a
problem with supporting this motion and
i'll
i'll leave it to that thank you council
ridgeway
uh yes um i just wanted to ask um
councillor gomez rini mentioned about
sort of making the homes warmer through
a government scheme but the government
has actually asked that greener home
greener homes warming
scheme and only 300 odd houses will be
done through the district council
really we should be supporting this and
then lobbying the government to
ins to bring that back so that every
home
every council tenant has a greener home
to help with the climate change
okay i think council dale wants to come
in there council dale
yeah thank you just just on that point
i'm not aware of that program being axed
i believe it was a short term
you know a grant period and we were
successful in getting
1.5 million from the government and we
put another
7 million into that to refurbish as you
say 320 homes there
my understanding is that there will be
further grants available and obviously
we'll continue
uh applying for those and we're actually
working up quite a
innovative scheme as part of vision
derbyshire to be able to access
longer term funding on a county-wide
basis
uh to to be able to continue doing this
work on a much much larger scale so if
anything we want to upscale that work
not
uh not reduce it so i i'd contest that
just in response to um some of
councillor shipman's points
i think he knows that that no one in
this in this chamber has ever said that
we wouldn't want to
uh speak to our residents councillor
kenyon has met quite recently with
uh some of the climate activists and we
continue to engage with our residents
very firmly
all that we're saying here is that
actually we care
the most about delivery about action for
our residents and that's why it's so
important that we do do things like the
million pound
investment in eckington swimming pool
that's going to be one of the
only or one of the most carbon neutral
swimming pools in the whole of the
country
as a result of this investment um the
the the
energy and emissions savings from the
investments that we're making into our
homes are going to be very very
significant i would rather that we were
the council that did
rather than that sat around and talked
about and that's that's the council that
we're leading
and the final thing to say is councillor
barker and councillor shipman's comments
around
you're quite happy to support a emotion
and a target
knowing that we might not get there so
what you're basically saying is
you don't think that we shouldn't engage
with residents but you're quite happy to
make promises to them that you can't
actually fulfill
which i think is far far far the worse
sin really as a politician that you're
making promises that you know
as a matter of fact that you cannot
deliver and so i'd far rather
have a sensible target as councillor
lewis says that brings people with them
uh you know we need to engage the public
properly in this we can't we can't
force targets that they are just simply
not going to live up to
and wreck the economy while we're doing
it so uh
i think that's all i need to say chair
but for those reasons we won't be
supporting this motion we're going to
carry on doing what we've been doing for
the past couple of years which is
actually delivering
for residents and actually delivering a
positive climate change agenda and
strategy
uh which councillor kenyon is doing a
fantastic job in leading for us
thank you chair thank you just that you
know council pickering i've seen
your comment i'll come back to it in a
second um
so any other comments or questions and
then i'll ask
council reader to exercise her write a
reply and then we have
um a proposal for a recorded vote so
i'll come back to that in a moment
council reader thank you chair
obviously some very disappointing
comments that i've heard around the
table
uh councillor gomesry they i'm
disappointed that you make assumptions
of what i know and what i don't know
which is very very disappointing and
i've brought this to the table because i
might only be
a district councillor as you say but i'm
a voice within this district council and
i think everybody should be using their
voice
on every single level that they can
possibly do to highlight
this climate emergency so for that
reason chair
i move the motion as it stands and i'm
going to request a recorded vote please
thank you so i'm going to take council
pickering as a second if i may
for the record and the council mark you
indicated you wish to have a recorded
vote so that's
that's the number of people required so
it will be
a recorded vote so i'm going to hand
over now to the governance manager to uh
to lead us through that please
okay um sarah stoneberg mickey i'll read
out the names
if that's okay
and we will do it in reverse order as we
have been doing
okay counselor p right
again counselor b right
four councillor winley
four council white has left councillor
welton
against that's the thaka
against cancer tate against
cancer stone
council shipment or
cats are rough
council rouse against
cancer row against
council ridgeway fall
council runway against
council reader absolutely for
council pal against
my supports against
council pickering's left council parking
okay
oh my apologies sorry council pickering
council parking
against councillor lewis
against councillor kerry
paul council kenyan
giving apologies sorry council jones
four
[Music]
or casa hancock
four council hall
against council gomez
councillor mark foster against
councillor angelique foster against
councillor emmons against council eliot
again council dayton against
answer dale again council cupid
again cooper
four council club
against councillor berkin
or council barca
council armitage against
council and cliff again
from
thank you the results are 4
16 against 26
and no abstentions the motion has been
lost
moved to item 9 exclusion of public i
move that the publicly excluded from the
meeting during the discussion of the
following items of business to avoid the
disclosure to them
of exempt information as defined in
paragraphs one two and three
part one of schedule 12a of the local
government act 1972
as amended by the local government
access to information
variation order 2006. do you have a
second to please
counsel dale thank you can we move to
vote
i'm going to stop the vote there chair
and share the results which is unanimous
thank you very much so can we
now stop the live streaming of this
meeting
you